Maybe that mild-mannered dude in the corner
was really the big bad guy.
Perhaps the hero was dead the whole time.
Or maybe everything we've seen is somebody's
hallucination.
Whatever the reveal, these memorable movie
moments caught us off guard and left us talking
for years to come.
Spoilers ahead.
Usually, movies are told in chronological
order, but much like its protagonist, Dr.
Louise Banks, Arrival isn't confined to a
single time.
In the movie's opening, we watch Louise lose
her beloved daughter to disease.
Naturally, we assume this is happening early
in her life, well before the renowned linguist
is asked by the military to communicate with
the heptapods mysterious aliens who've landed
on Earth.
Her job is to translate their complex language
so humans can talk with these otherworldly
visitors.
As she delves deeper into their circular alphabet,
though, the heptapod language changes her
perspective of time, allowing her to experience
the past, present, and future at once.
Before long, we discover that Louise actually
hasn't had her child yet.
Those flashbacks are actually flash-forwards,
visions of what's to come, courtesy of the
alien language.
Louise now exists outside of time, or more
accurately, throughout every moment simultaneously.
As a result, her perspective on concepts like
love are radically altered by the heptapods'
gift.
Sure, she now knows that heartbreak is coming,
but she heads into the future anyway, because
she knows there's a lot of joy waiting there
too.
It might just be the most emotional twist
in all of science fiction, and one that will
leave you both thinking and wiping away a
few tears.
A Beautiful Mind finds an Oscar-nominated
Russell Crowe playing John Nash, a real-life
Nobel Prize-winning mathematician who lived
a rather unusual life.
Early in the film, Nash is drafted by Department
of Defense Agent William Parcher to analyze
magazines and newspapers for hidden Russian
codes.
"You are, quite simply, the best natural codebreaker
I've ever seen."
It's an intense assignment, but when he's
not engaged in high-stakes espionage, John
seems to lead a normal life with a supportive
wife and an incredibly close BFF, Charles.
Whenever Charles shows up to visit, he brings
along his adorable niece, Marcee, who always
brings a smile to John's face.
Unfortunately, of the four most important
people in John's life, only one of them is
actually a living, breathing human being.
In reality, John is suffering from paranoid
schizophrenia, and the incredibly creepy Parcher
is just a hallucination.
There are no secret messages, no Soviet spies
lurking in the shadows, and no radium implanted
in his arm.
The real blow, however, is that Charles and
Marcee are also products of his imagination.
Unless you know the true story, the twist
comes as a devastating surprise and sends
this Academy Award-winning film in a disturbing
direction.
Colossal is one of the strangest movies ever
made.
This fantasy flick finds Anne Hathaway as
the alcoholic Gloria, recently single and
moving back to her hometown.
But as the self-destructive woman soon discovers,
her problems are a lot bigger than just the
bottle.
Gloria is psychically linked to a giant, Godzilla-like
monster, and whenever she stumbles across
a particular playground, the kaiju mysteriously
appears in the city of Seoul, South Korea.
"What's it doing?"
"It's dancing!"
"It's dancing like…?"
Fortunately, Gloria has a good friend to help
with all the booze and oversized beasts.
Jason Sudeikis plays her childhood friend,
a nice guy named Oscar.
The moment Gloria comes back to town, Oscar
does everything he can to help her feel at
home.
He gives her furniture for her empty house,
builds her up with all sorts of compliments,
and even gives her a job working at his bar,
which is probably not the best place for an
alcoholic to work.
But then Gloria realizes that there's a lot
of darkness behind Oscar's winning smile.
For one, he's also linked to another giant
creature that appears in the South Korean
capital.
And while he pretends to be a good dude, we
quickly learn he's a violent, manipulative
control freak, more monstrous than any kaiju.
And when Gloria tries to get away from this
creep, he threatens to murder countless Koreans
with his robot avatar.
"Either you drink that beer or I'll go take
a walk through the park later."
This turn from best friend to abuser is pretty
shocking, largely thanks to Sudeikis' affable
persona.
That said, there were probably a lot of women
who saw this coming, well aware that the real
world is full of Oscars.
One of the most unsettling sci-fi movies ever
made, Ex Machina finds a mild-mannered computer
programmer named Caleb winning the contest
of a lifetime.
He's been picked to spend a week conducting
a bizarre Turing test with his billionaire
boss, Nathan, played here by a super creepy,
show-stealing Oscar Isaac.
A brilliant inventor, Nathan has created an
artificial intelligence named Ava, and he
wants to see if his creation can convince
Caleb she's a sentient being.
Caleb quickly falls under Ava's spell, and
soon, the programmer plans to free his crush
from Nathan's grasp.
"Do you have people who test you and might
switch you off?"
“no.”
"Then why do I?"
After all, the tech tycoon has her locked
up and plans on essentially killing her.
Plus, Nathan's interest in Ava isn't just
scientific this guy has a thing for building
female robots that he can imprison and control.
Using his own tech savvy, Caleb sets Ava free,
and seconds later, the liberated android slices
through Nathan like he's a pat of hot butter.
If this were your typical sci-fi flick, Ava
and Caleb would probably run off together,
but in Ex Machina, things take a hard left
turn when Ava locks up Caleb and leaves the
screaming programmer to die of starvation.
It's a gut punch of an ending, especially
since Caleb seems so sympathetic.
Sadly, there's a good chance that he would've
jeopardized her shot at freedom in the outside
world.
In the end, he had to be tested and switched
off after all.
It's no surprise that the Armitage family
are the bad guys in Get Out.
When Missy Armitage and her husband Dean first
meet our everyman hero, Chris Washington,
they're way too friendly and far too polite,
which is never a good sign in a horror movie.
"By the way, I would've voted for Obama for
a third term best President in my lifetime
hands down."
"I agree."
Then there's their super creepy son, Jeremy,
who's oozing with menace whenever he comes
slinking onto the screen.
But with all these racists surrounding poor
Chris, his girlfriend Rose seems totally on
his side.
She'll definitely help him escape her family's
clutches, right?
Unfortunately, Rose is probably the most evil
member of the entire family.
After finding a box of incriminating photos,
Chris starts to realize he's the victim of
some really cruel catfishing, but he still
desperately hopes that Rose is on his side
when the Armitage clan blocks his path.
He begs Rose to give him the car keys so he
can escape, and for a moment, it seems like
she might pick her boyfriend over her own
flesh and blood.
She doesn't.
"Where are those keys, Rose?"
"You know I can't give you the keys right,
babe?"
The casting here is what makes the twist work
so well.
According to both Allison Williams and director
Jordan Peele, Williams was cast because audiences
would associate her with the far less evil
roles that she'd played before.
Sure enough, she does indeed seem pretty harmless...
right up until she doesn't.
Messing around with creepy European cults
is never a good idea.
That's a lesson our murderous anti-hero learns
the hard way in Ben Wheatley's Kill List.
This disturbing horror film is centered around
Jay, a family man whose marriage has fallen
on hard times.
And, oh yeah, he makes his living as a hired
killer.
You've got to put food on the table somehow,
and Jay stands to make a tidy paycheck by
killing three people for a mysterious client
who wants his contract signed in blood.
The weird thing is, the targets don't behave
like typical victims.
Instead of begging for their lives, they actually
thank Jay when he shows up for some hammer
time.
Things go from eerie to straight-up hellish
when Jay tries to kill his third victim.
Instead of finding his target, he stumbles
into a cult right out of The Wicker Man.
This whole assassination scheme was part of
an elaborate occult ritual, and it comes to
a bloody end when the pagans capture Jay,
put a mask over his face, and force him to
fight a cloaked hunchback.
The assassin makes short work of his opponent,
but after turning this guy into a shish kebab,
Jay discovers a horrific truth the hunchback
is really his wife and son, kidnapped by the
cult and tied together, with his son on his
wife's back.
Jay's just murdered his own family, much to
the delight of the deranged cult, capping
off a ghastly film with a truly gruesome ending.
Bong Joon-ho's Mother has a pretty standard
plot for a murder mystery.
A mentally challenged young man is accused
of murdering a teenage girl.
The police don't have any solid evidence against
him, but they need to make an arrest, so they
toss the disabled man in jail and trick him
into confessing.
Needless to say, his devoted mother knows
her son is innocent, and she goes from a mild-mannered
widow to South Korea's Sherlock Holmes, chasing
down leads, interrogating suspects, and putting
together a case to free her son from jail.
She even discovers a possible scheme involving
blackmail and a mysterious old man.
Now, in your typical murder mystery, the mom
would discover the killer's true identity
and clear her kid's name.
However, Mother subverts all those expectations
when the titular mom makes a simple but shocking
discovery: her son really did it.
Yeah, he's a sweet kid, and yes, he's mentally
disabled, but that didn't stop him from caving
in a girl's head.
It's a smart little twist that gets even twistier
when the mom murders an eyewitness to protect
her son.
Mother spins every thriller trope on its head,
but it also goes to show that nobody loves
you like your mother.
Every knife-wielding villain in a horror movie
has a special talent for taking out their
victims when they least expect it, but Ghostface,
the sinister slasher from 1996's Scream, seems
like he could pop up anywhere at any time.
When the masked killer first arrives in the
opening scene after terrorizing poor Drew
Barrymore over the phone, he seems to be lurking
around every single corner.
There's no way anyone can move this quickly,
but as victim after victim learns, there's
no getting away from Ghostface.
This dude is everywhere.
"Please don't kill me, Mr. Ghostface!
I wanna be in the sequel!"
In the big climax of Wes Craven's horror classic,
we discover the secret behind Ghostface's
teleporting powers.
Final girl Sidney Prescott is running for
her life.
The masked murderer has shown up at a high
school party, and he's slicing people left
and right.
Sidney has no clue who's under the mask, and
we have plenty of suspects.
Ghostface could be boyfriend Billy, horror
movie fan Randy, goofball Stu, or even Sidney's
own dad.
There are so many suspects, and it's impossible
to know who to trust.
And that's when Sidney makes a horrific discovery:
her boyfriend Billy is Ghostface… and so
is his best bud Stu.
These two psychos are working together for
a maximum kill count and providing each other
with an alibi.
"Movies don't create psychos!
Movies make psychos more creative!"
With two guys running around wearing Ghostface
masks, it's no wonder this bad guy was making
such good time.
M. Night Shyamalan's extremely weird filmography
has made him a punchline for many moviegoers,
but he'll always have one indisputable claim
to fame: he made The Sixth Sense, an all-time
great horror movie with possibly the most
famous twist in cinematic history.
The film finds Bruce Willis playing Dr. Malcolm
Crowe, an award-winning child psychologist.
In the opening scene, he's shot by a disturbed
patient he couldn't save, but a couple of
months later, Crowe is walking around and
seems perfectly okay.
Well, his marriage is falling apart, and his
wife won't acknowledge his existence, so that
isn't great.
But at least he gets a chance at redemption
by helping Cole Sear, a troubled boy who can…
well, you know.
"I see dead people."
However, Cole isn't the only one who can see
spirits.
The audience has been looking at a dead guy
since the start of the movie.
After trying so hard to talk to his wife,
Crowe finally realizes why she won't respond:
he's a ghost.
That gunshot in the beginning of the film
was actually fatal, and he's been a dead man
walking ever since, despite never realizing
it himself.
It was an ending that sent shockwaves through
Hollywood, and Shyamalan has been trying to
recapture that glory ever since.
But while a film or two has come close, The
Sixth Sense still stands supreme as the perfect
Shyamalan twist.
Everybody knows the twist from The Empire
Strikes Back.
Even moviegoers who have never seen a single
Star Wars movie know Darth Vader is actually
Luke Skywalker's dad.
The twist has permeated the pop culture consciousness,
and given us one of the most memorable, and
misquoted, lines of all-time.
"la la la Luke…
Luke…
I am your father!
Back in 1980, however, the Luke-Vader revelation
absolutely floored Star Wars fans.
Most of the cast and crew didn't even know
the truth about Luke's family tree.
According to Mark Hamill, the original script
read differently.
"The way we filmed it…
Vader said You don’t know the truth.
Obi-Wan killed your father."
Famously, only Hamill, James Earl Jones, George
Lucas, and director Irvin Kershner were aware
of the twist.
So when Vader finally announced his parentage,
everybody was gasping, from audiences to the
actors themselves.
And this shocking moment did a whole lot more
than elicit gasps.
The Dad Vader reveal sent the series in a
completely new direction, and laid the groundwork
for countless additional Star Wars films.
Has any other movie twist had such an enormous
impact?
The Last Jedi is one of the twistiest chapters
in the entire Star Wars franchise.
We learn that Rey's parents are nobodies.
Big bad Snoke gets cut in half.
Luke was a Force-induced illusion the whole
time!
It's twist after crazy twist, but the biggest
shock comes early in the film, when Luke Skywalker
reveals his Jedi days are done.
To set the scene, we have to go back a long,
long time ago to 2015, when The Force Awakens
was teasing audiences with the promise of
Luke Skywalker.
It had been over 30 years since fans had seen
the beloved Jedi Knight, and the entire premise
of Episode 7 involved a group of heroes searching
for the legendary warrior.
Finally, at the end of the film, Rey finds
the bearded Skywalker standing on a majestic
cliff.
As that John Williams music starts to swell,
Rey hands the Jedi his long lost lightsaber,
and that's where the film ends with Rey reaching
out to the hooded, silent hero.
Audiences had to wait two whole years to see
what would happen, but obviously, Luke was
going to take the lightsaber and lead the
charge against the First Order… right?
Not exactly.
In the years since we last saw him, Luke has
turned his back on the Force and wants the
Jedi to die out.
This little twist flew in the face of fans'
expectations, but really, they should've listened
when Yoda told us all those years ago that
the Jedi were never meant to be great warriors.
If Terry Gilliam, Karl Marx, Spike Lee, and
Rod Serling all teamed up to make a movie,
it might look like Sorry to Bother You.
Written and directed by Boots Riley, this
movie is absolutely insane in all the right
ways, and no description can do it justice.
It is without a doubt the most anti-capitalist
film to ever come out of Hollywood, and it
features perhaps the most deranged twist of
the 21st century so far.
The plot follows a promising young telemarketer
named Cassius "Cash" Green, who finds success
in sales by smooth-talking his customers using
what the film calls his "white voice."
"Like this, youngblood"
“Hey Mr. Kramer, this is Langston from Regal
View.
"I didn't catch you at the wrong time, did
I?"
Soon, Cash is promoted to the big-time, which
involves selling slaves to giant companies,
and eventually, he crosses paths with a psycho
billionaire played by Armie Hammer with big
plans for the future of business.
Up until this point, the movie has been incredibly
weird, but when Cash discovers the billionaire's
plans, the film absolutely loses its mind.
As it turns out, the billionaire is turning
people into half-human, half-horse monsters
so he can create a powerful but malleable
workforce.
That's right.
Armie Hammer is turning people into horses.
And if that wasn't wild enough, the movie
ends with Cash suddenly turning into an "equisapien"
himself.
It's totally bonkers, and no matter how good
you are at guessing twists, you'll never see
this nightmare coming.
From the Mandarin reveal in Iron Man 3 to
the Thanos snap in Infinity War, the MCU has
its fair share of shocking twists.
One of its most jaw-dropping moments, however,
comes in Spider-Man: Homecoming, when Peter
Parker picks up his date for the Homecoming
dance and finds something way more intimidating
than the average suburban dad.
Throughout this superhero flick, the wall-crawler
is trying to find a balance between homework
and crime fighting, hanging out with friends
and trading punches with bad guys.
You can't really go to parties or participate
in the academic decathlon when you've got
an entire neighborhood to protect, and it's
hard to get a date when you're constantly
trying to fight the Vulture, a winged thief
who sells weapons made with alien technology
to local thugs.
Eventually, Peter puts his crime-fighting
on pause and works up the nerve to ask his
crush, Liz Allan, to the dance.
He gets his suit, learns to dance, buys Liz
a nice corsage, and shows up at her house,
ready for a fun evening.
That's when the door opens to reveal the Vulture
himself.
As it turns out, this murderous villain just
so happens to be Liz's father.
Suddenly, Peter isn't worried about making
a good impression.
He's just worried about making it through
the night alive, which becomes even more difficult
when the Vulture realizes why Peter's acting
even more nervous than the usual high school
kid meeting his girlfriend's father.
"Very lucky he was there that day."
"Good ol' Spider-Man."
Like Uncle Ben always used to say, "with great
power comes a really complicated love life."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.